so tell me do you feel like
women
um typically understand the consequences
for their choices or do you feel like
it's a surprise later it's a surprise
100 surprise later 100 is a surprise
what do you guys think yes a surprise
yeah i think
we choose choose more on just our
initial
emotions
oh yeah yeah
yeah i agree yeah i think some don't
care as well
do you think
i agree with that
that's crazy though like you all
understand
that it's a surprise later you all still
make choices that that doesn't consider
yeah because sometimes you don't think
things through so yeah
women or i don't know some women don't
think things through and it's impulse
and they go for it where sometimes it
could be a bag of emotions like our
hormones go up and down all the time so
sometimes i could be great because i
can't be great and i can't necessarily
always balance that but then this is why
you self-reflect and you learn you're
then cognizant of those emotions and
then you understand that when you feel
that way you stop and think instead of
acting no but men men you don't do
that's why
you said earlier
men do tend to be more logical whilst
women tend to be more it's easier for us
to say that when we don't go through
something every once a month like it's
easier for us to say it when we've never
had to do it
i'm not trying to say yeah it is easy or
harder i'm just saying that for me
personally yeah when i self reflect when
i try to teach myself growth to
understand myself better yeah when i
feel a certain way i stop so when i was
younger i used to get into a lot of
facts i was very angry person i would
smack people up but then when i started
when i started to understand the
repercussions of my actions the way it
could land me
when i get angry at you how young would
you like you taught you how to do that
my parents and how you know
and then i didn't then i i carried on
um myself well we're chemically we are
chemically different every single day
but i don't but i don't think that's an
excuse for poor behavior no no just
because we didn't think something
through like why why should the men have
to deal with that but then that's like
saying how um
sorry like men
are prone to being more like
aggressive and stuff like that like
people say that but then is that an
excuse for them to no they ever feel
it's not is
it goes both ways yeah but i think the
difference is when when women have a
standard were praised for it and when
men have a standard they're shamed
for for example um fat fat phobic
okay
um slut-shaming those are those are all
to take away the consequence for women's
bad decisions
um
okay so where whereas a woman if a woman
says oh i want to keep my standards high
i should never settle
the girls gas her up everyone gasses her
up wait i even asked the girls a
question like
so if if is it okay to ask your guys
he's hot
no i feel silly what do you girls think
let's be honest is it okay to get off
guys yeah definitely yeah so do you
would would you sorry ask them hi yeah
you think it's silly to us no martial do
you think he's okay no i don't think
it's silly to ask but i don't think it's
needed
like are you talking about like a dating
app
yeah so like a guy you've never seen
before you find him attractive is it
okay to ask him his height absolutely
yeah if you're like a more taller girl
you need to know if okay the man is tall
because some people don't so reverse um
is it okay for a man to ask a girl about
her weight on a day or not
if you want i mean if you want if that's
you know you can i don't believe in the
height thing because like i've got
friends that like four four so the
question first of all is it okay
i might have asked me on hinge before
how fat how how big are you okay what
about girls what do you think if you ask
me and i sent you a text saying okay
yeah i'm eight stone you're going to
think oh i know exactly what that looks
like
i could be eight stone and five foot
left without asking you whatever it is
so whoever you think it's okay because
wait no hi yeah which is
your weight is within your control
whilst your height is something you
can't control so wouldn't it make more
sense to be okay to ask about something
like weight
in in
compared to height i hear what you're
saying but that's why hinge is great
because a guy has to put his height on
there anyway so you don't need to ask if
he hasn't got it on there then there's
for a reason these are some of the
double standards that where women are
praised for certain things that men have
to they have to face the reality
straight on yeah and it's the same thing
with only fans like if a man has no
skills and no job he's homeless
a girl can make six figures in a month
just starting and only fans if she was
born attractive
but i say if she's born attractive if
you're not born attractive then you're
going to be homeless like everyone else
trisha paytas makes a lot of money on
only fans i do not think she's trying i
don't think you need to be attractive if
you go big back and big boobs yeah i
think you're pretty confident stuff like
that
funny enough the highest paid like
people in sex work are people that look
young that that look like kids yes
because men want that a lot of men want
that though
they're they're attracted to fertility
the younger you know if you survey men
between the ages most women peak at like
22
or 21 some some even earlier because if
you survey men from 20 to 80 and you ask
them what age do you find women the most
attractive they'll say 22 23.
i think even on netflix they did a blind
smell test both for women and men women
who tend to be more attracted to men
with high levels of testosterone whilst
men were attracted to younger women and
that's based on smell so that was what
she had high um
so women so so they got men to sweat
they got men to sweat and then
based on smell who would they most
attractive to without being able to see
the guys and they was attracted to guys
with higher testosterone when they did
the same for men to women um when were
attracted to women who were younger but
what was because they were young because
what was it that made them
attractive
as well it's fertility so men are
biologically predispositioned to want to
spread their seed
like
do you know what the gangas khan stat is
where like it's like one out of every
100 or one out of every 50 people
in china related to kangaskhan because
he was just slaying so many hoes
like i had so many concubines yeah but
we have different reproductive
strategies like a man's reproductive
strategy scatter gun spread your seat to
as many people as you want whilst a
woman whilst a woman's is to to bag the
best they can get and hold on to it
because that's what that's what ensures
safety
to make more people
you're spreading your teeth to make more
spread to spread your genes
so to make more people so to make
i know so
that means you're gonna make a baby
right okay but you're just spreading it
you're just
out here no condom just scattering
around we are biologically predisposed
to do that that's what we're born to do
can i just scroll back to summit real
quick sorry um just where you guys were
talking about your number with a girl
would be 10
would is that like lower than what you
would go to just where we were talking
about double standards i just want to
check that
real quick yeah so you're like you
wouldn't sleep with more than 10 girls
that's your cat yeah i would have sleep
more than 10 goals yeah i'm asking you
both at 28.
because you you wouldn't
you wouldn't wed a girl that slept with
more than 10 guys
just you know where you were talking
about double standards before yeah so i
just i was just checking like i was just
kidding she wasn't your number bro
what's your cat when did you say no i've
had way too much sex i want to stop now
and settle down listen yeah we play by
different rules isn't it
i'll i'll i'll land on that so we
obviously as men and women we play by
different standards yeah so when i say
men are men women are born of valley
watchmen have to create their value here
so for a woman acquiring sex is as
simple as walking out in that street
you're going to get sex right now yeah
so you can have zero value like um
tangible value and just being born a
woman means you're guaranteed a seat at
the table when it comes to the sexual
marketplace as a man before you're
granted the opportunity to have sex you
have to become something you have to be
worth something so how can you then
place the same value on sex for men
as women and that's that's and that's
the only double standard that doesn't
benefit women
and it's really not that crazy to yeah
with the provider role
so we're okay with that double standard
because honestly if you're okay with
that double standard why isn't it not
okay for a woman to want someone a bit
bigger and want that provider then
because maybe she doesn't find a
provider in someone that is she is okay
yeah because you were saying
it was not but then it doesn't mean
she's any less lovable if she's a
certain weight does it not whereas like
if it's a high [ __ ] at least for like a
lot of girls like taller girls they just
like the taller men because it gives
them
a sense of comfort
a girl is that making you all women want
tall men that's not true no because
because like i'm five two i don't need
so like
okay what does
a woman of a certain weight give you
whereas like a man of a certain height i
mean they're attracted to to think
physical yeah hips naturally isn't it
genetic like the wider the hips it's
more yes yes so that's why women but
that's why women are sorry not women
that's why men are attracted to the
hourglass figure right the wide hips but
yeah that's not that doesn't mean rolls
that just means wide hips yeah and and
men can't help that they're not
attracted to bigger women in general
that's why you see the most attractive
or the most powerful
men
end up with models yeah that has money
not because everybody else no i'm saying
we're taking the people the two people
with the most options exercises
yeah are they they typically are thinner
women and rich men yeah a lot of models
are just slim and slender they don't
really have the hips to have what you
yeah do you know what i mean whereas
like you can get not always but a lot of
curvy girls secrets
i don't think men are looking at least i
don't think you guys are looking at
victoria commanders being like oh yeah
that's going to be perfect for my child
you don't know what girl i'm pretty sure
i mean guys have different types that's
true some guys prefer you know more of
the instagram body where it's the
hourglass and some guys prefer more just
the skinny slime yeah that's true but
at the end of the day it's still we're
talking about in general men prefer
thinner women yeah
yeah
but remember that not everyone has the
same
um
basically everyone has different options
and what the what they prefer and so
when we're
shouting out these stats or whatever
let's let's be
um
rather
objective about it and say that it's
some not all because i know i know men
personally that
that prefer um
a woman who's bigger than them
yeah and i know
um
i know men who are short are
but they want a really tall woman yeah
yeah
i think that's what oh no the short guys
they love the top they do yeah
we don't we don't love them like it's
not
but but but the thing is we're talking
about in general like if we
if we talk if we spent this podcast
talking about the exceptions we'd be
here all day we didn't even get moving
yeah there would be no point in having a
conversation we still need to mention
them okay
tell me what i can i can't mention on my
show
no you're right exceptions don't make no
sense to the bigger society but i'm i'm
always not always but i'm mostly
reception to the rules so when i say
things i'm thinking about speaking to
the mic so when i say things i'm
thinking things how how i think and how
i react but i also understand that
society doesn't think like me most girls
will quote exceptions not not not the
rule and it's just to alleviate
themselves of the responsibility of
having to be factual in the moment do
you think so hundred percent happen
accountability is the one key word when
you throw that word around like how many
women really claim that and i can say
i'm truly accountable for my actions we
all here just said once you ask the
question about um
um being of understanding the the the
byproducts of certain decisions we make
and we all know that yeah we make
impulsive decisions yet you still make
the wrong decision so accountability
will tell you that okay to better myself
and make better decisions i'm gonna take
accountability for my bad decisions and
then better myself but you all willingly
said like oh no while i still make
impulses now but that doesn't mean that
we don't learn from previous things that
we've done
in the same way that you um learnt from
like your aggressive behavior when you
were younger that doesn't mean that we
don't learn from that and are conscious
of our behavior
if that happens again
from what i've seen i don't think most
girls do i think they go to toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
after toxic relationship then at 28 29
when they're running out of time their
biological clock is ticking they run to
the nice guy but in terms of
relationships that's because they
haven't learned they haven't understood
what was wrong with the relationship
before
their own behavior right how many times
do you have to learn no but they haven't
learned they don't know what what 20
times they don't know what was wrong
with 40 times i don't know i don't think
you could put a cap on how many times
because people learn people no not only
because for me
i've been in certain situations i'll
never go back to so i learned very quick
very young
probably why i'm single now because if i
was going if i was going with the
joneses and going with the flow
i would probably be of a man now but i
learned very young very quickly
that i have that
it's a lot of
it wasn't right for me i wasn't ready
for relationship when i was young
because therefore i took myself out of
that stuff and worked on myself if i was
just to go free and then i probably
would be with someone else i think
there's a lot just like a strong person
right
back well i mean don't get me wrong some
girls do learn and make better decisions
but the problem is we're just thinking
about us
because why does a man have to deal with
that but in the same way why does he
have to deal with a girl that can't
learn young like why why wouldn't he
just marry a 22 year old because she's
yeah that's that's what also what's
crazy about that though you're saying
that but then men also prefer
young women that haven't learned that
mm-hmm
it's like when they come out that's how
what so exactly so for young women yeah
and they haven't learned they haven't
they haven't learned